welcome everybody to the live cast uh
today we're talking with Yasmin and not
Tim russwick about a wonderful game
called Cult of the Lamb we're gonna go
in depth we're gonna talk about uh some
of the game designs some of the things
Rick or I have not played this game
Yasmin our wonderful guest is going to
walk us through uh some of the game
design and all that stuff before we get
started Yasmine do you want to tell
everybody a little bit about yourself
and uh kind of what you've been up to
and you know kind of stuff you're doing
Game Dev yeah sure
um so hi thanks for having me uh I
um share Game Dev tutorials over on my
YouTube channel I'm also a musician so
uh I kind of dabble in making music
videos and game engines and in my day
job I'm a tattoo a technical game
designer so yeah that's me and if anyone
watching at the moment wants a an audio
course by gamedev TV spam yagman X
Channel like go over there find Yasmine
like we really want that course we've
been asking for it forever so you know I
dabble in music is a a code for saying I
really really want to create a Game Dev
TV audio course wouldn't that be amazing
[Music]
uh she only does everything I think that
sounds valid that sounds valid right
Indie Dev cool all the houses all the
hearts
okay
welcome to Cult of the Lamb I'm really
excited to share this with you because
I've been playing it a lot on Twitch uh
and it's a really addictive game Let's
press play that would help
uh
yeah so I'll just show you kind of what
happens a little bit about the game for
the people who don't have never seen it
before Oh yeah of course well the way
that this game was explained to me was
it's Animal Crossing but you are the
head of a cult and uh it's extremely
dark and I was like oh that sounds
really like really um just fun because
there was a lot of games that came out
after Animal Crossing especially around
lockdown and stuff that were just to do
with like building up a community and a
little world of your own that you could
go off and explore in but I feel like
this game has just taken it one step
further and taking it away from the
cutesy even though it's still got the
cutesy art style but uh so are you
starting starting from the start or is
this you've already played I've already
started yeah so I I thought I'd already
like show you how it is now because
there's a little bit of aim like a
learning curve and it takes a little
while to get into maybe an hour or two
so here I can really show you everything
so these are all my followers
um so this is the kind of like animal
crossing-esque aspect to to it as you
can see some of them aren't very well I
should probably tell that one to like go
to bed or something I think these PCS or
these people that I can't make like
their actual folks playing somewhere so
if you play this on your own
um they will just be NPCs and the
interesting aspects of this is um
they're all randomized so they actually
have personalities and their
personalities can either like help you
on your base or they can hinder you on
your base they might get sick a lot they
might rebel against you and then you
have to put them into jail or kill them
because you can kill them
um but so the names that you mentioned
these are actually my twitch followers
so I played this on Twitch and all these
people are people who've like watched me
on Twitch and became my followers which
is really interesting as well because I
mean you get to make up your own story
especially because they all have their
own personalities like some of them
don't sleep they just work all the time
so the hard workers and you tell them
like what you want them to be working
working on throughout the day so even
just this kind of gameplay Loop of
taking care of people building up your
base as you can see I've got tents here
and I've upgraded some of them haven't
upgraded all I've got logs that I need
to like collect and then this if dude is
going to carry on doing them for me I
need to make some food for my followers
they're not not gonna get ill if you
hate your followers you can make them
food that kills them if you really want
to because I mean this is a cult this is
not a happy nice game
um so yeah just doing this
so if we if we can zoom up a thousand
feet into the air and just have a look
at what we're trying to do is the world
this entire area that we've got like
this map that we've is that the entire
world or do you have many different
levels you go to or is it is it an open
world that stretches off forever what's
the name space
so let me show you this is
the map you're in the teleporter okay so
there's a so there was a map um I think
I've unlocked everything I'm not sure
though there could be more spaces uh
because it just keeps on um like zooming
out basically to show you something new
that you didn't even know when I first
started playing it I literally thought
it was the base and then there is a
dungeon crawling road-like aspect to it
as well which I'll take you to in a bit
but as I've been doing the roguelike
bits and progressing through the main
story which is you're trying to release
the demon that sets you back on this
Earth to be a cult leader so actually
you're you're kind of doing everything
for him
um you've actually unlocked all these
different places so down here
I can go and fish so I can get like good
fish for my for my little my little
followers I also managed to like this
Lighthouse and now I have some pilgrims
here who also pray to me and um I can
take their prayers and basically it
unlocks things for my base
which makes my life a lot better I can
like fish if I want to so you've got do
you have a currency you're trying to
grow I see hearts in the top left the AI
throw the UI
UI looks pretty pretty smooth the whole
art style looks super continuous it's
really nice how would we describe this
art style it looks
um like cardboard cut out pop-up style
Paper Mario kind of style a little bit
I mean it's a
five days and it says 2D Sprites on like
a 3D environment
um but yeah normally normally if I was
to see that I'd expect a depth to things
but it looks like they're yeah a lot of
Paper Mario the Rock at the front left
there looks like it's intended just to
look like a a plane everything looks
like planes as opposed to zooms away
when you go over there as opposed to
making it look like it's isometric with
depth
yeah yeah it is all 2D so like here the
visibility you've got like a Kona view
that you can like it pierces through it
yeah camera's interesting too like it
kind of Zooms in on whatever it thinks
you're focusing on yeah yeah that that
is true that's um pretty easy to do in
cinemachine as a side note there's a
couple of courses we go through that in
terms of the when you get into a
particular
um State then it zooms in or you get you
know hit a trigger you can have it zoom
in zoom out so there's no excuse for us
as game developers not to have Dynamic
cameras if we're using Unity
um I don't know unreal so much from a
dynamic camera point of view
um Yasmin I don't know if that's oh it's
so simple yeah it's so simple to just
ease in and out of Select cameras which
are there and just hidden obviously
about the player but I'm just looking at
his animations like there's so many
details to just make this game amazing
like it's so cute he looks adorable then
if he walks left to right he's got this
such an evil look about him just like
he's just loving just being evil yeah we
talked so much about polish and it's
something that I think I don't know if
you agree with this but I think it's
better to make a tiny game that looks
really polished and and has all the
bounce and zing and wiggle and and
personality to it than it is to make a
game that's bigger you know a couple
more levels a couple more features a
couple more characters that doesn't
quite have that polish to it because
people will forgive you I think if if
like wow that was amazing but I only
there's only an hour of it I want more
they'll forgive you more on that than
saying well I kind of played for 10
minutes and then lost interest so I
don't I just don't even know if there's
three hours to it
yeah yeah that's so true
um so I'll just tell you a little bit
because you you did ask me about the the
UI so up the top left
that is
um
the hearts are to do with when you're in
the Dungeon Crawler so we'll go in there
in a bit
um because you can actually
I don't have anything enabled but you
can you can upgrade stuff so that you
can kind of use things in your base to
allow you to have more Hearts before you
go in and do that
um which will obviously benefit the main
story
um so this here is basically everything
that I've unlocked for my base so little
things like a lumber yard all of our
resources that we need no it's exactly
that yeah so we're unlocking elements to
to then unlock more elements so you see
this hard white line here we can't get
to anything in this section until we've
unlocked enough within this you don't
have to unlock them all to unlock the
next one but you have to choose at least
enough which then it also makes it
random for each player because you can
choose to kind of play the way that
you'd like to play and have your bass
have the things in it that you want yeah
and you can make it as as difficult or
easy as you want as well because we have
things like demonic summoning circles
which allow one of your followers to
have the spirit of a demon in them and
then you get to take them into the
dungeon with you so you can have like
multiples of those I think this is for
two yeah so you can have two demons and
basically they're just little AIS that
are like helping you out
chewing at things or becoming a bomb
just something to give you a bit of
extra help but if you don't want them
because you you're like really good at
the game you don't want any help
obviously you don't need to unlock this
if you don't want to you can unlock
everything else around it
the first half of the game you're
actually you see yourself die and then
um you meet the demon and the demon
brings you back to life and then you
start within the Dungeon Crawler just so
you're getting a good grip of like how
to move how to attack and things like
that and then you get sent here I
believe with the first follower that you
have to indoctrinate and there is a
there is a man who kind of takes you
through all the things that you need to
do so he says you know make sure that
you build
um I think it is this Shrine you have to
build this Shrine first of all because
this is what gives you your major
upgrades
and then from there you just kind of
figure it out and uh go on
and what do your followers actually
doing are they are they like
um in a say if it was an RTS you might
have Villages and the villagers are off
harvesting gold and running back to the
base or off chopping down trees or
coming back oh yeah in this game what
are your villagers do they have a
resource collection role I know you said
before about some of them get sick and
some of them are a pain in the button so
I'm going to do whatever but what's
there what's their responsibility I
guess what's their job on the team yes
man what are they doing so honestly most
of them are such a pain in the freaking
ass so like sacrificing them it's fine
by me well not my twitch followers but
this is the great thing about whether if
you're streaming it the experience is
just 10 times better
um because
so you can tell them what to do so I
could say you know I want you to be
collecting dogs and one of them will go
here you can only have one at a time do
one thing and because I've only got one
log thing or one I've got another Stone
collecting over here
then the rest of them default to praying
to the Statue and that's how we get
these
prayers that I'm receiving and then I
can upgrade my stuff
um phrases feeding the tech tree you
showed us before yeah exactly yeah
feeling the tech tree yeah and then um
when I am live streaming this the twitch
uh will get notifications the twitch
chat will get a notification saying
would you like to help or hinder the
streamer and um if they choose help then
perhaps these followers are a little bit
more helpful they help me with cleaning
up the the base they help me with um
with harvesting or something like that
um if they choose hinder they could
choose something like they have they
poop everywhere or they're sick
everywhere or you know they're they're
easily angered because if you don't look
after them as well because you do have
to talk to them and look after them and
you can give them bribes and things and
dance with them they actually become
unfaithful to you and then they can make
everyone else become unfaithful to you
and the less faithful followers you have
the less spread you're getting to your
Shrine and you won't be able to use them
as sacrifices so you won't be able to
get their demons which will help you
through the dungeon and they won't be
able to if you die in the dungeon you
get to sacrifice them so you can carry
on through the dungeon so you want to
keep them happy
so I would love to see the dungeon part
of this now yes okay a few times let's
do it and so it's interesting that the
game has these two modalities this is a
full-on Dungeon Crawler hack and slash
type game yeah
um and and then
there's the you know the I guess the
farming aspect to it or the you know the
city building aspect whatever one would
call that other aspect
um it's interesting having those two
modes sometimes when games try to pull
that off it seems like it's two totally
separate games just kind of join
together and how does this feel does it
feel like there's a a reason to be
coming in and doing the dungeon crawling
and it's a you know it's a good break
from doing the farming is it work well
this this relationship between the two
modes
I believe so yeah because I mean it fits
with the narrative because you're a cult
leader and the only reason you're a cult
leader is because your demon has brought
you back from the dead
um but also you use your followers as
kind of extra lives like I touched on
previously if you die you can sacrifice
one to come back and
um a lot of the time if you just spend
most of your time in the base just doing
kind of that gameplay Loop over and over
you do run out of resources and it can
become very grindy which is the case for
a lot of games like that like Animal
Crossing I've been playing Disney dream
light Valley recently and I can get
quite grindy so here it's kind of like a
shortcut to that so you can do um you
can do this and actually so you know how
in like um Dungeon Crawlers and robots
you get uh a choice on the map of where
you'd like to go within your next area
and it will show you what what you will
gain from that area so that you can
choose kind of how you'd like to play
um you can actually choose a resource
specific areas so say if I was when I
ran out of wood and I need some wood for
one of my quests for my followers
because you do actually get Quests for
them as well then I can come in here and
I can hopefully gather some wood and as
you can see as I'm hacking away at the
area I'm picking up poo I'm picking up
grass I'm picking up Stone so I'm I'm
getting resources it's like a broom come
true
sounds like being a dog owner I'm
picking up food grass stone oh yeah I
guess you can Chuck this thing
um interesting can you if you have
another fight in there particularly with
one of those boss kind of guys maybe
these are a bit different but I think
what we can learn from the encounter you
had just now when we're creating an
enemy that was really cool is the enemy
turned towards you and then it triggered
its slash animation and you know fight
fight and in that time you as a player
could run around to the other side and
hit that to avoid it so sometimes the
enemies that we create in these sort of
hack and slash games seem a bit
um a bit too repetitive because all
they're doing is just coming towards the
player and hitting the player moves they
just turn the other way and they hit
that way so that's a cool thing for us
to take out of it just fix for whatever
it was the one or two seconds fix the
direction of the attack like and so the
player feels clever running around the
other side and hitting that little
mechanic alone I think is is enough to
make an interesting
um enemy to fight against but yeah it's
also an interesting way you know
essentially he was shooting a
heat-seeking missile at you again a lot
of games will just it'll shoot straight
away and come straight at you and maybe
even be a homing missile missile we move
it'll move as well but I really like
that it popped it out gave you a moment
to see oh it's coming and then it shot
towards you so once again you can feel
clever by timing Your Role to get out of
the way of it so yeah yeah it's cool
there's lots of these little enemy
design mechanics we can take out of this
you know related to that the uh UI I
noticed something that I thought was
really really cool when you get hit your
health bar also shows above your head
which is which is a really cool little
detail because one of the things I've
noticed with making games like this is
that there's so much action taking place
in the center of the screen the UI can
get lost very easily your eyes aren't
there they're focused on the center so
putting something really important like
the health right over the head when you
get hit is I think a really nice touch
um yeah I have not met this this person
before
um it seems to get new people all the
time whenever I go through so this is
also by the way how new areas open up on
the map usually you'll find them in the
dungeon for us so you do have to go and
do this if you want to progress the over
the overall story
um you'll find them in the dungeon for
us and then they'll say hey why don't
you join me in this place and then you
know when you get out of here somewhere
new is going to be open and ready for
you on the map which is exciting I think
they've captured that cuteness really
well and so a lot of people are just
going to see the character and say that
resonates with me that that style or
that look the personality of the
character seems really neat and I think
that's something that's really worth
iterating on many times in your game
until you can find a character where
someone this one people like oh it's a
little lamb oh and then as you were
saying before sometimes he does some
evil stuff you're like oh but he's evil
and I think that's worth putting so much
time into until you get it right because
that'll draw people to your game and
it's I that popped into my head because
Lottie is asking what about this game
first Drew you to it and sometimes it's
the intangibles of I don't know it just
kind of felt good or looked interesting
and it can be just even the personality
of the main character can do that but uh
Yasmine what what did draw you to the
game when you were first you know
hearing about it or or considering it oh
it was honestly it was just the
explanation of Animal Crossing but you
are the leader of a cult and I just
thought that idea alone was genius
because like I say there were so many
you know I I hate to say the word clones
but there was just a lot of games like
Animal Crossing after Animal Crossing
came out because it did so well and I
completely understand why because there
was a lot of people who craved something
that they could feel like they could
have fun with friends or they feel that
they belong in and there was something
to do every single day you know during
covert and lockdown and things and then
all these cutesy cozy games came out
because I feel like it is a nice time
now for people to want to play cozy
games
um but the idea that like it's still
cozy but it has a dark side and you know
it's exploring dark themes in a cozy
manner I just I thought that was quite
unique I haven't really seen that done
many times and you know
I do love Animal Crossing and I've like
I said I've been playing Disney Dream
like Valley I love
um playing games where I feel like I can
be connected with the characters around
me but I get frustrated with the
gatekeeping that there is within those
games where you feel like there's
nothing to do for that day and you have
to pull it down and go do something else
and for this that it was just the Best
of Both Worlds uh because I've always
been interested in Hades as well so I
was like ah I'll play this it's a bit of
both
so you know what too there's a sort of
Rhythm to it and I don't know this but
it does look like the character is
moving twice as fast as kind of the rest
of the stuff
um yeah and it that kind of Rhythm and
and kind of speed is important because
it's kind of like contrast in a visual
uh sense the speed of an animation so
that stuff is kind of really important
I'd love to see how it looks in engine
with it all just layered up because it
must just look like a mess when you look
at it from a different perspective
because the camera's obviously at a very
specific angle to get all of these
things lined up because it's all just
different layers of 2D
yeah what yeah that's interesting as
well how would it how would we go about
building this if this was in unity I
would
um like as we were talking about before
it would be a 3D space and I would just
have my Sprites plopped in there I
wouldn't be making this as a flat 2D
game
um it would it would be 3D with with
assets dropped in there
um so yeah that shouldn't shouldn't be
too difficult to play some and have them
look good yeah is that's something
that's a little bit trickier but
it's really good Parallax too if you
notice yeah the background objects it's
very light but it's there you know as as
with all these things when we're playing
through these games the important thing
for us to learn from it is to take this
screen and say how does that compare to
the game I'm working on or the game I'm
thinking about how can I get some of the
movement how can I oh yeah lighting I
need to do something there that texture
on the ground is interesting how can I
get a bit of a texture on the ground and
to to take that not to try to get this
level of you know art Excellence because
this is super you know whoever created
this who really knows what they're doing
but for us to get the elements of
movement the elements of lighting the
elements of you know character pacing of
their animation the scene is dripping in
detail there's so much of it and there's
not a lot of like super unique elements
to it but there's a lot of a lot of
stuff placed here and it's really well
placed there's so many of these systems
and maps and stuff yeah it's a it's a
massively system system driven game uh
it's very impressive really does feel
like two games joined together Like a
Dungeon Crawler is the one complete game
and then a you know a farming simulatory
Community Builder type thing is another
game
so here we've got a new follower
um I actually might do that one so we
can come out and I can show you how the
followers are made yeah and this one
would be a shop
um I don't know what the cat represents
actually but it would be a shop for
something some cat thing uh this would
be the resource resource room so you
would go in and there would be no
fighting it would just be rocks for you
to hack away at and just get as many
rocks as you like uh so yeah this is
where you can kind of choose what you
want to do
yeah so this is the new follower
um you can get them in many different
ways which also helps to make the game
more exciting sometimes they'll be
um they'll be
um
captured by some enemies and you have to
kind of like kill them to to free them
um but this one's just on its own
obviously and yeah
and vulnerable that character looks yeah
all of his family's been killed all the
special buttons around him
but yeah so we'll we'll talk to this
this dude
it wasn't supposed to be certain type of
animals I don't know what type of animal
that one was
but um follower awaits indoctrination
yes so you get to do this when you go
back to your
brother like someone's starting a gaming
a TV course for the first time are they
just the twitch followers they're just
the names that have been drawn in and
plopped on top of people or are they
actually doing something is it them is
it from their accounts do they need to
have an account like what's what's a
relationship there socially
so great question
um it's not multiplayer
um
I'll show you how the how the followers
are built when we get back to the base
um but basically
you can either build your follower
manually or you can start a raffle and
then everyone watching the twitch stream
gets a pop-up on their video and it says
do you want to enter the raffle you say
yes and then if you win
um you get to control how that follower
looks so what animal they are what color
they are and then that follower has um
has your name above their head I find
it's a very it's a very good way to to
chat with
people in your chat especially those who
might not be as active in twitch chat
there are a lot of people who like to
watch Twitch not so many people who like
to talk in twitch
um so actually if they join the raffle
and get a follower then I'll be walking
around and maybe I'll say their name and
we'll we'll begin a story about them
through this follower and what they're
doing and what their character is and uh
it actually I feel like it's I feel like
it's a really good game for for twitch
honestly it's really cool yeah it just
changes up how you play it when you're
streaming it what's that thing this
seems like an easy battle
that was an observation
so that's um I'm stealing that person's
prayers I guess you
[Music]
were up this is the guy who's swinging
in One Direction and then oh no he
flipped he made me look a full okay
sorry keep keep going oh he made Mila
before
maybe he's just uh
catches you off guard what are you
collecting when you're out mowing the
lawn there
so I'm collecting uh Stones things in my
base basically so like okay grass to
feed my followers Stones do you see that
anywhere on on your screen is there a UI
showing yep on the left this is what I
mean it I I always miss it it comes up
on the left
um so it'll pop up this is Calamar like
calamari I think I think that's quite
fun
um so they just kind of taunt you when
you're almost at them so it's calling me
a sniveling coward
these are other demons
these or that's
that session I'm not sure if that other
they must be other demons right there
definitely are the god-like entities and
they have shackle
chuckled The Entity that has brought you
back to to praise him and basically by
by
killing these ones each of the shackles
that's holding your God down gets
Unshackled so I think I've killed one so
far or maybe two
um so I think I've got three or two or
three to go uh but yeah so these are the
main bosses that you want to kill
there's a lot of narrative and intricate
systems and interconnected like yeah
this is amazing so many details
I suggest so he just made all of my
followers deathly ill so now he's made
my life harder when I get back to the
base
so yeah everything does impact
worthwhile for you to go through this
battle
well you hope so because also if I win
the battles my followers will be way
more faithful I won't have to look after
them as much so each system does benefit
the other really well um or hinder the
other well because if I lose pretty
badly then actually they lose Faith so
wow okay yep
yeah because at first when you're
explaining all this it seemed like two
unconnected games
but the more we explore with this the
more it seems very connected
they've done a really really great job
at it
um so this is the cards where you get to
choose how you would like to help
yourself so I could have a disease heart
which is a heart where it damages
everything on the screen when I'm hit I
believe that only happens once but that
can be quite useful
um or you get a 10 chance to deal a
critical hit so I'll just grab that one
it's interesting Tim and I have talked
about this a few times that I see 10
chance to get critical hit I'm like who
cares 10 isn't enough for me to be
excited about it if it was 50 then I'd
be like whoa every every second hit
potentially it's going to be a critical
that's really cool so I like it when
games are more more exaggerated with
what they give to you a game like this
is awesome because I think there are
multiple player types most multiple
personality types and multiple Gamers
that could play the same game and love
it for very different reasons you know
what I mean like the whole Animal
Crossing aspect I I watched a YouTube
video this for the first hour and 95 of
the time they were just in the dungeon
like that was like their favorite part
and Yasmine when you started you were
showing us all the cool stuff about the
Animal Crossing part of it and talking
about how great that was so yeah yeah
like there's different there's so many
different things and I think people can
see the great in so many parts and
pieces and that's what makes a good
overall game
yeah it's a really good point um because
I will say
um in the base part of it
um there is a area I think it was the
one
it was one of the areas that I showed
you you get to buy Cards and I haven't
done that before because I just have not
bothered to like level up how many cards
or you know what my chances are within
the dungeons very much
um so if your focus was the Dungeons and
you wanted to make sure you got good
cards and good options you would be
spending all of your
currency
um on those stores to make sure that
you've unlocked all of the cards because
I've still got so many that haven't been
unlocked I think I've just got mainly
the default ones so it's probably also
why I'm not getting very good options to
choose from I could tell you're a
collector
even when we're doing a game analysis
you're like I just gotta go get all the
grass thank you very much it's so
satisfying that I know we're not
listening with um audio but the audio
feedback is so satisfying and I don't
know to me it's just I've got it I've
got to do it but that goes on my way no
it does the feedback and the audio sound
effects and the way the animations work
all that polish goes a long way and if
something feels really good to do
players are going to do it more often
exactly you get a little Rumble as well
every time you hit something that that's
also really nice
feels good
yeah I'm a big proponent of really
focusing on the things in a game you're
going to do a thousand times and polish
those and if you just do that you can
make way more progress and if you put a
little bit of polish on a bunch of
things
making it too complicated for players as
well
so you might as well just try and
simplify everything and make it the best
it can be
which I'm sure this game could have
easily been way too complicated to be
honest with the amount of systems it's
got going on
yeah I I think it's definitely already
had plenty of its future creep right
like it's got a lot of systems in it but
I think they had fun with it I think
they managed a way to find everything
feel uh cohesive which is cool
definitely
and I think there's a there's a right
way and a wrong way to feature creep so
if you make a game and it's a good game
and you say you know what to be cool
let's add some more secondary weapons
because we've got that on our list of
you know our wish list of backlog things
to do okay cool we're ready to add
secondary weapons how should we do it
well you know every now and again when
you get into a dungeon you can choose
between them and we'll start off with
two and then we'll just keep adding a
bunch more and that'll be cool and fun I
think that's an okay okay way to do
feature creep I think the bad way to do
feature creep is where you say no no our
game is not ready it's not good enough
until we have secondary weapons or a
choice of different weapons we can't
release it or we can't show it to people
that's I think when feature creep can
really break your whole process this is
the boss battle right yeah this is a big
box Bell oh okay got my case okay so the
boss battle wasn't that me a guy that
just taunted you
oh yeah
oh yeah um
so you have to do each of the dungeons
multiple times
um because they have cursed
followers you you find out that they're
cursed after you kill them
um kind of protecting their domain and I
believe there's four per dungeon so you
have to do it four times and then once
they're out of the way a new door gets
unlocked uh and you see your progress to
unlocking that door each time you defeat
um
a kind of mini boss I guess this would
be for people who haven't haven't played
a lot of dungeon Crawley type games I
think way back in the day it it well I
was gonna say there was a way of doing
it now it's a little bit different but
that's not true there's two two Styles
one is you have the whole dungeon you
can run wherever and you're not going
from sort of closed room to closed room
you can just sort of meander around the
dungeon oh no oh no oh yeah I forgot I
always forget
um I can sacrifice so I'm gonna I'm
gonna sacrifice this one the only one
that isn't a follower oh isn't a twitch
chat
oh that'd be difficult having to
sacrifice them and then you come back
yeah
yeah oh nice oh wow
that's all you needed
I didn't realize you came back exactly
where you died
that's awesome like yeah yeah
it's
very forgiving you know I I totally
think that this game was made for um
four fans of of Animal Crossing and and
games like that as well because this is
um medium like not normal mode I'm not
on hard difficulty and there isn't easy
difficulty as well so you can play it
how you want but it's yeah it's
definitely wasn't made to be extremely
gruelingly difficult like some
roguelites can be right
it definitely seems like a animal
crossing Binding of Isaac kind of mix
yes oh yeah because I really like Barney
Isaac as well
uh okay which is my reward
why what's the question what's the game
design question we're answering there um
and there was a there was a literal
question in our chat before does it feel
tedious to have to replay the level
multiple times I think the the question
of are you making Animal Crossing are
you making Binding of Isaac or are you
trying to make both and usually what
we'd recommend is don't try to make both
because you're going to make two half
okay games but if you've got the the
time and the team and the inclination to
do so you can give meaning to one by
having the other so if you've just got a
Dungeon Crawler you're like why am I
doing this like what's my point
you know I'm just trying to get from A
to B maybe when you get to the boss
battle if it's procedurally generated
maybe you're trying to get a score or
play for as long as you can or progress
as far as possible enter the gungeon you
know you're just trying to get as far as
you can it's a roguelike so you know die
and you have to start the whole thing
all over again but but what is there
beyond that maybe you've got a meta map
you're trying to unlock some stuff but
then have this entire other system this
whole sort of community cult farming
followers kind of system it gives
meaning to that I'm trying to collect
things for this every bit of grass I cut
is so I can do a thing in the you know
my other part of the game and then the
other way around as well after a while
the Farming Simulator type stuff can be
like well I've done the things there's
not much more to do but if you've got
the meaning of okay now I need to I do
some things so I can Dungeon Crawl
better so so long as the the if there's
a little bit of a risk there I think I
don't know what you think about this Tim
but if someone you're saying before
about types of players if someone loves
Dungeon Crawlers but hates Animal
Crossing and someone loves Animal
Crossing but hates hack and slash then
do you feel that you run the risk by
having two games in one that you're
gonna accidentally not satisfy either of
those two people by making them do the
thing they're not interested in what do
you think about that
I mean it looks like you can minimize
either game if you don't like one of the
gameplay Styles you can minimize the
time you spend there is that correct
so yeah absolutely you kind of have to I
a little bit but it seems like you can
kind of maximize your time where you
want to spend your time which is cool
the other thing that this does is it
Loops really well so you play through
this dungeon you earn a bunch of stuff
you get a new follower
all of that stuff then relates back to
the like Animal Crossing part of the
game and then you you know have them do
whatever they do they Farm or whatever
then you need more resources
then you go back into the dungeon so
there's this really cool loop to it
um the the other thing that I want to
say too is generally we talk about games
in terms of genres and one of the things
one of the things that a game like this
does is I think it it kind of starts
with a concept so like it would be very
easy for the developers of a game like
this to just say let's slap on an XP bar
right like boom done everybody knows
what XP bar does it's great it works but
instead they put Like a Prayer statue
right where you collect prayers and
those prayers do different things and I
I think that's really cool to
thematically add things that make sense
in the game like the fact that you're
collecting followers right like that's
not a thing you do in traditional games
but it makes total sense in terms of a
cult type of game so
um there's a lot of thematic stuff like
that that fits perfectly that even
though it is generally if you're a
beginner game developer making a game
like this is not a good idea at all it's
it's way too complex and there's a lot
of Design Systems that are heavily
reliant on each other there is so much
design in this that we're not even
seeing that's behind the scenes and and
balancing and how all this stuff works
but I do think it works and I think the
success of this game on Steam kind of
shows that it does work healing room are
you getting oh yeah so on this I'm I'm
being a cult leader so I'm um giving my
sermon and uh I can I can do like little
rituals
um
you can pull his animation is like
giving the sermon he's like it's very
neat it's so cute
um the movie talk to them the more uh
they give you these like plaques the
plaques
um and then you get to gosh how would I
even explain this you get to unlock
uh new rituals for the followers and
rituals will help you on your base so
it'll either help you manipulate your
followers to do what you want them to do
or it will allow your followers to be
easier to be kept happy I suppose so
this one is perform ritual right or
Temple to distribute money to all your
followers to increase their loyalty
um so obviously you lose money they gain
loyalty or perform ritual at your
temporal image all your followers donate
money to you so it's how do you want to
be as a cult leader do you want to be
the most evil cult leader you want to be
or do you want to be someone who's a
little bit nice you know
hmm
this is one of those things that doesn't
make sense if you're making a roguelike
or an animal crossing genre game
but thematically it makes total sense
right it fits in this world perfectly
like absolutely you can call your
followers into a little chapel and do
rituals in them like it makes sense so
part of part of what's helps what helps
this game work is the affordances and
the kind of um
thematic stuff that this game kind of
has in it and what the perception of a
cult leader would be so a lot of the
stuff works for for reasons outside of
the game design itself they've actually
gone that far and you do actually you
can see how close to someone you are
which is this little bar above their
head
um and once you fill up the bar you get
the little plaque which allows you to
unlock more rituals and they've even got
a system
um for each wow characters have yeah
thoughts and so everything that you do
for all the base uh or whether maybe
you're not even at the base and they
have seen someone else take a poo or or
their lover has died
um yeah they have this uh system for
their thoughts it's it's so complicated
and they all have their own
personalities so this is their their
this person's personality is and that
affects what they want to do around the
base in terms of work and also how much
they want to sleep or how often they get
sick
yeah
there's a lot of thought that's been put
into
the song Maybe This is the old grumpy
man in me but I just look at this and
I'm like how much work did this take man
like how much work did they put into
them that's a lot of work and I can see
you going through there well it's okay I
I was saying you could go through that
um some of the modification or
customization of characters yeah like
and yet another system to build Tim it's
like oh my goodness this is what the
twitch chat get to get to do if they get
their own follower by the way just so
you know so they get to choose like all
these things
yeah so yes another system
they can customize this with the chat
itself
uh so the chat
um there is an overlay uh you have to
set it up as the streamer you have to
set up a a twitch extension that is a
cultivant twitch extension and then
there was an overlay that appears over
the stream itself
um you click to enter if you want to and
then if you win the raffle then yeah
they'll get a screen similar to this
that's on top of
my screen so on top of the video uh and
they yeah get to choose the form and the
color and and the variance the variant
is like their markings
and they don't get to choose a traits I
don't believe
um they're they're randomized but yeah
and this is this is nowadays if you want
a if you want to make a game successful
without having to be a marketing genius
then the way you do it is make a game
that is very twitch streamable or
YouTube streamable YouTube videoable so
that people out there with all the
followers can create content using your
game and then the followers right
watching it saying this thing's pretty
cool I'll go get this myself so you know
this kind of integration I think is is
becoming a a really important tool in a
game developers toolkit how can we make
it so twitch streamers want to play our
game oh let's do this you know let's
have the followers be you know the
followers of the cult be the followers
of the twitch streamer there's an
interesting palette parallel there as
well which is kind of fun cool so you're
giving ammunition to the streamers and
to the content creators yeah I made a uh
I made a tower defense twitch enabled
game where I would build the towers and
twitch chat would choose north south
east or west to spawn units and um Not
only was it surprisingly easy to do the
twitch integration wasn't that
complicated at all I thought it was
gonna be way more complicated than it
was but also exactly like you said Rick
significant increase in engagement
everybody wanted that game on there all
the time to the point where I was like
okay what about my other games guys like
calm down like this is We're Not Gonna
constantly play this game I don't even
like this game
uh so yeah it's a great Point even
people watching us live now if there was
something for folks to do then it
changes the interaction
um yeah that's really cool
thank you for that run through Yasmin
it's very excellent
um
and then any questions from our chat or
uh while we're waiting for questions
from the chat
um we can fire some questions at Yasmin
as well
playing it with you two as well because
I think you know when you're playing it
I mean it's so interesting because
people say to you oh if you're a game
developer does that ruin the enjoyment
of the game but I'm very good at
switching off my My Game Dev brain just
when I when I get immersed in the right
type of game yeah yeah so yes it's
really cool to pick it apart with with
YouTube as well you brought up some
really good points
yeah I I have the curse of I have to
understand how everything works all the
time which makes me a good developer I
think because I can you know I
understand the pieces of things but it
is a curse that like any kind of
entertainment ever I have to understand
the intricacies of why it works and I
annoy people because I don't shut up
about it but plus side of that is I can
make content about it easily
yeah we have a question here from uh
Lottie and I guess it's for you as does
it feel tedious to have to replay the
level multiple times how do they make it
not tedious
um so I think you made a good point
about the length of it
um it's quite short I mean you just
watched me go through it just then I
think it only took what maybe 10 minutes
and we stopped to chat as well so if you
want to you can kind of just whiz
through the dungeon section it's fine
it's randomized as well every time you
go in there there's going to be
different sections um different rooms to
choose from on the map also uh we just
ran into a new character that I'd never
seen before that keeps happening
um even if I go into the same dungeon
sometimes I'll meet people that I've
never met before they'll be you know a
new character so sometimes it's not even
about
um the combat it'll be a whole section
about foraging or a new character or
something so it throws in a lot of
different surprises in there that keep
you on your toes
um and also like I said the actual the
base building part of it I feel like
that can become way more grindy and and
tedious so actually going in and doing
the dungeon crawling bit for me is is
the fun bit where it just speeds
everything up a little bit because you
you get to then progress in your base as
well because you're getting everything
that you need to progress there avocado
fire asks how much does the art
influence the success versus the
gameplay the art seems really good
obviously we don't know that we can
never know that but I would say
Aesthetics is a huge part of this what
do you guys think
oh definitely
it's a beautiful game
it's detailed and it's animated well and
it's got a very cute art style that's
diabolical that I I love that I have a
lot of my art styles spacer and that
kind of same thing of like a cute little
lamb that's also a demon worshiper I
find that hilarious so
I think there's often what what draws
your attention into a game and what
keeps you in a game and I think art is
very much draws you into the game you
look at it you say that looks cool I
want to play it so if your art looks
crap then people are less likely to give
it a go
for sure yeah
you art can just sell stuff by itself
like good screenshots good trailer can
just sell a game all by itself like
without any descriptions without
anything so keep that in mind I mean
it's unfortunate for the programmers of
us out there that uh maybe have a little
art challenge or you're trying to make a
game I get that but it is you know it's
important it's important to think about
I do think as well that the the art
would change the whole feel of this game
I mean it is it is about a cult and
indoctrinating followers and having
sacrifices and helping a demon
um it's all fun and games because you
see it like this in a very cutesy manner
but you know I I feel like it would just
totally change the whole feel of the
game if it was more gritty and darkness
yeah and I don't feel like it would have
the same audience
it was really weird exactly
um yeah completely different audience I
agree with you on that
um it's a question for you Yasmin uh
what genres of games do you usually work
on yourself
um so personally horror uh I do love to
dabble in the dark so I did make um an
indie horror game called Perfection uh
which was a game where you try to become
perfect and it all kind of goes wrong
it's basically just um a walking
simulator but
um just exploring themes of I guess
Perfection
um but yeah so those are the types of
games that I like to work on because I
don't know from for me I mean even when
I got into game development I was
actually just more into telling stories
or exploring themes in An interactive
way which obviously games ended up being
the best format for that so I know
everyone makes games differently some
people start with a mechanic and then
they build upon that some people start
with
um you know start with the story and
I've always started with okay what what
message do I want to tell and how would
I want the player to feel after leaving
the experience tell us a bit more about
your like the type of role that you have
on the game team and and what that means
like what you do in that role someone
asked specifically about that technical
artist
oh are you a technical artist or a
technical designer Tech designer Tech
designer yeah so from what does that
mean
okay so a tech designer um is basically
kind of they bridge the gap between
programming and design so what I do is I
am often I mean I I'm in all the design
meetings and things like that but
usually I'm the one who's deciphering
all of the designs and thinking of what
the designers want sometimes I get to
come up with the designs myself as well
but we think more about Pipeline and
performance and the systems that we
already have in place and we need to
have a bit of a more of a wide
understanding of how things work and how
they affect one another within the game
to make sure it doesn't break
um so we're often talking to programmers
as well so that's kind of like
technical designers job role just to
think more of the mechanical technical
sides of of a game's mechanics and
Designs like Is it feasible and how can
it be how can it be implemented are you
doing some of the implementation
yeah okay so so to give like kind of an
analogy then it would be like uh idea
guy says we want giant explosions for
every bullet and programmers are like uh
what does that mean like how big
explosion small explosions whatever and
you're in the middle yeah they're kind
of saying okay well we can technically
do this with our particle system and if
we do this this way we can is that kind
of yeah generalization of
of it yeah and we've got to make sure
that we ask the right questions Tech
designers are asking questions all the
time so we go okay you want the
explosions but uh how big do you want
them and do you need them all to be the
consistent size like do you want control
over that is is there a possibility they
could change in the future XYZ and then
programmers okay how would you implement
this what do you need from me and then
we've got to come up with like a a good
system to to allow the designers the
control that they need to tweak it and
get it worked right because it's never
right the first time
um and then also allow the programmers
to to actually do their magic and put it
together yeah because I've definitely
seen scenarios where you put designers
with programmers and the programmers
just get frustrated as hell
kind of one more question from Lottie
how do you get into that job field what
experience was needed and did you work
up to it or step into it
I
did you I think it's the games to get to
get into the industry as a job or did
you like
straight out of did you go to school and
then you got a job from that or what was
your flow
so I used to be a web developer
um so I knew like JavaScript and HTML
CSS
and that got me into uni
um uh because they actually didn't need
any grades because they just knew what I
was doing and then um I studied computer
game Arts thought I wanted to be an
artist realized I much preferred being a
designer and just coding in c-sharp and
unity so I had like The Pick of the
artist which was great so I made
Perfection that's when I made Perfection
during my uni days as well as like a
couple of mobile games as well
and uh after that honestly I think it
was a little bit of the fact that you
know I made Perfection and I uploaded it
and it kind of got picked up by a few
YouTubers and like kataku I think as
well so it did all right
um but then also I was going to game
events uh under the guise of the AG Man
X which is my YouTube channel and I
would make sure that I did my research
on every Indie Dev that was there or as
many as I could and then I could go up
to them and talk to them about their
games and like learn about their games
and I used to play games and then I used
to reach out to indie game devs and ask
them if they wanted like an article on
their game or a review or something
um so but I was doing that for years
um so it was a little bit of skill
because you definitely need skill and
obviously you need to understand how to
make games and how games are made
um but I think also mostly it was just
putting myself out there and trying to
get the contacts and it's it's sucky to
say but it really is who you know
because I also came out of uni luckily
because I've been spending all those
years making those contacts I could have
a lot of people to say you know this
studio is looking or this studio isn't
um and even then it took me six months I
think of of just purely looking for a
job
um to get a job into the industry and I
found a trainee position which is an
entry role into AAA and there are quite
a few that do that to be honest I think
PlayStation either is still doing it now
or they were doing one a couple of weeks
ago but they're looking for an intern so
there are quite a few AAA Studios that
look for interns
um but yeah it's a lot of hard work but
if you're dedicated uh and enthusiastic
you don't I don't think you realize you
don't have to be as smart as you think
you have to be you don't have to be
Godsmack especially if it's an entry
role they just kind of want want to know
that you're enthusiastic and you're
willing to learn and you know the basics
that's kind of it yeah
and you're a nice person yeah awesome
yeah thanks for joining us today so good
to have you uh hanging out and thanks
for showing us Cult of the lamb
um a lot of it's a deep deep game so I
appreciate you taking us through
radically beautiful dripping with design
and if people watching want to uh hang
out with Yasmine uh over on her Channel
yagman X search for that and you'll find
her and sounds like you hang out on
Twitch from time to time so go over
there and you never know you might end
up being a follower in her Cult of the
Lamb game
look at that did you do that Tim gee
whiz
I posted it in the chat so the Link's in
the chat everybody oh that's how you do
it nice excellent thank you
is horrible I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay we do need to end the stream we
need to get out of here oh there's
someone someone's that don't listen to
them they're just trying to rile you up
team just see Rick this is why we don't
do this breathing exercises it's okay we
don't mean it construct three is lovely
it's a good engine it's easily in the
top 10 engines it's not a problem let's
breathe I know it only goes 2D and it's
not really 3D and it's not really a
problem
thank you everybody
it's okay it's been amazing
I appreciate you being here Yasmine
thank you so much for sharing everything
with us oh thank you it's really nice
and we'll see you back on here on the on
the live cast sometime soon hopefully
yeah yeah yeah why not always happy to
be here
have a good night everybody